and I'll bring in the onybody smell
trophy right to be top of the morning
everyone I brought some burgers and
fries eat up the protein soaks up the
sugar first you take the cow to the
killing floor I came here for the same
reason people go to the zoo Shh
look at that nature is amazing okay
there is no food finer for Leslie that
means whipped cream or no it's whipped
cream we're looking the whipped cream
cans Oh got some okay Something Wicked
This Way Comes
once you peruse a book with your thumbs
go to the one who succumbs I'll be
attached with a little gum unless they
give me a break I hate riddles and other
such nonsense I want that on the record
but something wicked with a book is my
ex-wife from the library which means I'm
the one that succumbs I'll be attached
with a little gum good God
that woman is good follow me to the
sheltered snow only 22 Clues left to go
22 well this is the woman I've chosen to
love well I guess there's nothing to do
but spend the entire night methodically
solving this puzzle there's no way we'll
finish in time okay I'll just make a
list of places she and I have been
together and hope we luck out and find
the last clue we'll split up cover more
ground move Leslie thanks to your
annoying prying last year I'm sure you
remember my birthday's coming up I know
I know no parties you hate parties
correct oh you know that wild goose
chase you sent Ben on for Valentine's
Day scavenger hunt I also do not want
that yep I understand I absolutely do
not want to solve a series of riddles
and clues each more intricate than the
last you understand
yeah I got it run good I do want that
please do that for me Ron hello Andy
it's quiet in here where is everyone the
government is shut down it's in every
newspaper how long is gonna last no if
we're lucky this building will be empty
for months with current and projected
deficits we need to cut expenditures by
32% let's make it an even 40 oh that's
not necessary slash it slash I am an
official member of a task force
dedicated to slashing the city budget
just saying that gave me a semi right
off the bat we sell City Hall let's
somebody turn it into a large gas
station or at t.j.maxx Ron that is a
very creative idea but we don't want to
sell any of our major assets because we
don't want to lose out on any future
revenue streams
I hear that don't worry I have tons more
ideas okay so sorry
new ringtone don't cut anything without
me this really attractive woman is my
girlfriend Lucy hello Lucy Oh impressive
handshake Thanks my father told me that
a limp handshake was for weak men and
communists he hated both well done Tommy
zette bacon on your turkey leg they
called it a Swanson tomorrow the Parks
and Rec Department is receiving a
commendation at the Indiana State House
for bringing the Harvest Festival back
and although it's purely ceremonial it's
a huge deal for me to go to the
Statehouse I couldn't care less about
the commendation but Indianapolis is
home to Charles Mulligan's Steakhouse
the best damn Steakhouse in the damn
State I have taken a picture of every
steak I've ever eaten there June 2004
porterhouse medium-rare Bearnaise sauce
January 2000 they call this one the
enforcer February 96 a steak Reba
the whiskey Lagavulin 16 the lady next
to me a [ __ ] specifically my ex-wife
Tammy okay this is this is the first
time I ever went there oh look at me
just a kid it's rough in here is it
always like this
I wouldn't know don't like strip clubs
smells like a wet mop in here and I get
the feeling that every one of these
women is running a low-grade fever
you're one of the good ones run wait a
minute
hello beautiful
[Music]
strippers do nothing for me I like a
strong salt-of-the-earth self-possessed
woman at the top of her field your
Steffi Graf's your sheryl swoopes says
but I will take a free breakfast buffet
anytime anyplace
excellent work everyone particularly you
Ron you have one very satisfied citizen
what did you do for her fixed her
pothole is that a euphemism no then
great work in fact she's out in the
hallway and wants to thank you herself
if you're here to complain about the
pothole I guarantee I did it correctly
actually I'm here to ask you out for
dinner
really well I hope you're not the kind
of man who needs to ask the lady out I'm
a middle school vice-principal I don't
screw around does that freak you out no
on the contrary
so dinner please and thank you well
it'll be casual no need to wear makeup I
begrudging Lee admit that the 3-1-1
program is a moderate success I'm still
not sure why the citizen decided to come
speak with me in person but I'm just
happy to see a government program
finally work this came out yeah I am
starving I haven't had lunch since
yesterday so I'm gonna head over to
callaghan's oh no no no don't go there
they totally skimp on pickles let me go
to bighead joes for you they have the
most insane burritos I don't much go for
ethnic food yeah trust me they have one
that's called the meat tornado literally
killed a guy last year you had me at
meat tornado beer Garth um wasn't
sticker outfit Kali was the fourth round
Indianapolis Colts know how to draft so
well they really do Andy this was
delicious it's awesome it's a whole new
meat delivery system thank you so what'd
you say we go out to the parking lot run
a few pass plays to burn off the
calories you are an unstoppable good
idea machine I like Andy I'm surrounded
by a lot of women in this department and
that includes the man
oh hey man reading the defense Reggie
wait morning Leslie er oh man I am so
tired
I took a half-shift at the hospital last
night and I had this really weird
patient
weird how I probably shouldn't talk
about us one of the grossest things I've
ever seen
talk well this guy came in he got his
hand stuck in a Pringles can and he
tried to cut himself out did he use
three and a half inch serrated buckets
of blood he passed out over his arm and
slumped onto the floor with a bunch of
very good question April answer her yeah
the bone showed everyone in the universe
loves a gross medical story boom I win
it so when I finally clean up the vomit
I found the toe I forgot about the tail
or did we crazy right
the story is awesome indeed thank you
for sharing Jenny Ann was getting a
little chummy when people get too chummy
with me I like to call them by the wrong
name to let them know I don't really
care about them that's a genius move
thank you you're welcome
Lester
that's a good shoeshine
what the command I don't know what
happened
frankly I emitted a noise the noise was
involuntary
sometimes a sound is just a sound
you